materials make distinctive sounds when
you hit and scratch them these sounds
can tell us how objects behave when we
physically interact with them they can
convey whether an object is hard or soft
smooth the rough and rigid or deformable
in this work we consider the material
understanding task of predicting what
sounds with animation you hit it we give
an algorithm a silent video of someone
striking things with a drumstick we ask
it to produce a plausible soundtrack to
go along with it to perform this task
well the algorithm has to recognize the
materials that are being hit and the
actions that are being performed but we
don't explicitly tell it about these
things instead it has to learn about
them by recognizing patterns in the raw
audio visual signal our algorithm takes
a video sequence as input and it
predicts a corresponding sequence of
sound features after a network predicts
sound features we synthesize a waveform
by matching these features to a database
of impact sounds and transferring the
best matches here are some soundtracks
that our algorithm produced to help
understand what our models doing we can
look at the video clips in our database
that it's transferring audio from these
are the audio clips whose sound features
are most similar to those predicted by
our model
instead of synthesizing a waveform by
transferring sounds from a database we
can directly invert the sound features
with a simple parametric synthesis
method this can help us understand what
information is contained in the sound
features that our model predicted our
algorithm can get confused when the
motion of the drumstick resembles a head
but it does not actually strike a
surface we conducted a human study where
we ask people to distinguish real impact
sounds from sounds that were synthesized
by our model we found that our sound
predictions fool participants more often
than those of baseline methods including
simple image matching models